الجيش السوداني يقصف تمركزات للدعم السريع
في الخرطوم وام درمان وقوات الدعم ترد
بمضادات طيران
نقابه اطباء السودان تدعو لفتح ممرات امنه
للمساعدات والهلال الاحمر يصف الوضع في
الجنينه بالماساوي
الامم المتحده تقول ان الشبكات الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع رفعت اسعار السلع
بنسبه 60%
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
مع اقتراب هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد روسيا تقول
ان النيتو يزيد من حجم وكثافه تدريب قوته
بالقرب من حدوده
[موسيقى]
طاب يومكم واهلا بكم الى الساعه الاخباريه
مفصله لاهم الانباء ونخصص جلها للشان
السوداني هدنه نظريه هكذا هو الوضع في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع حيث
لا تزال مواجهات مستمره وان خفت حدتها حيث
لا تزال طائرات الجيش تحلق في سماء
العاصمه في المقابل ترد قوات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه اتفاقات هدن سابقه لم
تدم طويلا تفاقمت معها الاوضاع الطبيه
والانسانيه حيث وصف الهلال الاحمر
السوداني الاوضاع في الجنينه بالماساويه
ياتي ذلك فيما لجا السودانيون الى النزوح
حيث تقدر المنظمات الدوليه اعدادهم بنحو
نصف مليون شخص منذ بدء الصراع وهو العدد
المرشح للزياده في حال استمرت المواجهات
[موسيقى]
طبعا كل المراكز العطله بحاجه الحرب
نحن برامز ظروفه الخاصه
نعمل في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم
امكانيات الماء موجوده عندنا
سحب بعض الادويه والمعدات
بتجدد الاشتباكات رغم الهدنه السادسه
المعلنه بين الجيش ودعم السريع واضاف
المراسل ان ذوي الانفجارات سمع في الخرطوم
واندرمان ورصد البراسل تحليقا لطائرات
الجيش السوداني في سماء العاصمه حيث
استهدفت تمركزات تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
في المقابل ردت قوات الدعم السريع بمضادات
ارضيه في محيط القصر الرئاسي
هذا ونشر الجيش صورا لضبط مخازن اسلحه قال
انها تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع حيث تحتوي
على الاف الذخائر
تحت الفرش مخازن اوروبيه تحت الدولارات
تحت الجو المخازن الارضيه تحت الجبل
العملاق
كبير جدا جدا
في الاثناء لا تزال الاتهامات متبادله
بشان خرق الهدن المعلنه منذ بدء الصراع في
اخرها بيان للجيش حمل قوات دعم السريع
المسؤوليه لخرق الهدنه في الاحياء السكنيه
البيان اشار الى وقوع اعمال نهب للبنوك
والمحلات التجاريه في محيط الساده الهلال
باندرمان لافتا الى هروب اعداد كبيره من
قوات دعم السريع من اندرمان باتجاه الغرب
وقال الجيش ان السفير الهند في الخرطوم
ابلغ عن اقتحام السفاره وسرقه ممتلكاتها
ورغم اعلان جنوب السودان موافقه اطراف
الصراع في السودان على وقف اطلاق النار
لمده اسبوع اعتبارا من يوم غد الخميس قال
يوسف عزت مستشار حميتي قال للعربيه ان
قوات الدعم السريعه لم توافق بعد على
الهدنه كما اكد انهم لا يرفضون الهدن في
حال ضمان الالتزام بها متهما للجيش
السوداني بخرقها
معلنه
والطيران يخطف المدنيين ويخطف مواقعنا لم
يتم الالتزام بكل هذه الهدن فمن السابق
لاوانه
النقد الهدنه لمده اسبوع تبدا بعد نهايه
لا نحن نتعامل مع قوه
وافقنا على هدى ام بواسطه امريكا بواسطه
السعوديه لم يتم الالتزام على بالهدنه ليس
لدينا مانع في هدى جديده لكن لابد ان تكون
هنالك جهه ما تقول من خلق الهدنه
دعا عدد من المواطنين بجنوب دارفور ضعوا
طرفي النزاع في السودان الى ضروره وقف
الحرب والاقتتال مشرين ان الصراع خلف
اثارا اقتصاديه كبيره منها ركود السلع
وارتفاع الاسعار والله يا اخي نتمنى من
الحكومه يعني يتوافقوا ويتفقوا
ويتعاونوا واحنا كلنا سودانيين مع ان
الفرق بين احمر اصفر اخضر
الدعم السريع يا ابنائنا ما في حاجه داخل
السكر
في امان في الاحياء
كل المواطنين يا جماعه ان السوق داعي من
بكره وبعد بكره وقدام والبنوك هتفتح واي
زول يا جماعه يجي يفتح دكانه وما يتخوفوا
نسال الله ان يوحدنا سبحانه وتعالى اولا
الوحده كل الناس يعني تتوحد عشان تصل لبره
الامان باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى
هدى متتاليه في السودان كلها باءت بالفشل
ولم تحقق الاهداف المرجوه سواء بالتوصل
لوقف دائما لاعمال العنف او فتح ممرات
انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي في السودان ليتم
خرقها باستمرار وسط تبادل الاتهامات
بالخرق بين طرفي نزاع
مقترح هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود
بالالتزام ومن ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو
متطابق تكررت ست مرات على مدار اسبوعين في
السودان دائما ما ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها
دون اي نتائج مرجوه مع تبادل طرفي الصراع
الاتهامات بخرقها
اولى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تم تعب ببساطه امريكيه لكن
الانفجارات والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليق لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من
قوات الدعم السريع
خروج كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى اندرمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا لفتح
باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد ولم
تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح ممرات
انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم المتديه
الى عمر العربيه
في السودان الاشتباكات تتواصل رغم الهدن
وضع انساني كارثي وتحذيرات دوليه من
الاسواق اما شرطه السودانيه باتت امام حد
اخر سببه التفلت الامني في البلاد اذ نظمت
حملات لمحاربه الجريمه بهدف بسط هيبه
الدوله وسياده حكم القانون الحملات شملت
في يومها الاول مناطق الفتاح العضليين
وسوق الدخينات وسوق الكلاكله اللفه مرورا
بابو ادم والعزوزاب وسوق الشجره بينما
نظمت الحمله في يومها الثاني في شارع
الشهيد ابراهيم شمس الدين ومنطقه السوق
الشعبي بالخرطوم وابو حمامه والمرافق
الحيويه اما حمله اليوم الثالث شملت مناطق
امتداد شارع الرميله مرورا بصك العمله
ومخازن السكر والمنطقه الصناعيه الحملات
حققت اهدافها المطلوبه بمشاركه الق
المسلحه لتامين الاسواق والمناطق التجاريه
الهامه والمرافق الحيويه
اذا في جديد التطورات في الشق الميداني
وصلنا هذا العاجل تجدد الاشتباكات في محيط
القصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم حتى هذه الساعه
على كل حال معنا الان مباشره من الخرطوم
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه عمار ما تفاصيل
المعطيات المتعلقه بتجدد للشبكات في محيط
قصر الجمهوري الان
صباح الخير نادين يعني منذ الصباح الباكر
وحتى هذه الدقائق طالعنا وشاهدنا واستمعنا
الى تحليق جوي من الطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للقوات المسلحه والتي بحسب
معلومات ميدانيه استهدفت اهدافا عسكريه
لقوات الدعم السريع في عدد من المناطق
خاصه بحسب المعلومات الوارده الينا الان
ان هذه المناطق تركزت ما بين مدن العاصمه
الثلاث ما بين مدينه بحري في مناطق شرق
النيل وكافوري وعدد من المناطق المتاخمه
لقياده الجيش من الجانب الشمالي والشرقي
وهذه الاشتباكات ايضا كذلك وما فيها من
تحليق حربي كثيف في هذا الصباح ما بين
الطائرات الحربيه المقاتله وطائرات
الاستطلاع التي دائما ما
تتقدم ومن ثم الطائرات الحربيه لتنفذ تلك
الاهداف العسكريه هذه ايضا الهدف العسكريه
التي قصفها سلاح الجو تركزت في منطقه
القصر الجمهوري
ومناطق السوق العربي وجميعها مناطق متاخمه
للقصر الجمهوري وعدد من الشوارع الشهيره
في تلك المناطق مثل صينيه الجندول وعدد من
المنطقه التي تتركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع فيما يخص السوق العربي الكاميرا
الان من خلف تنقل ونشاهد من خلالها اصعده
الدخان التي ترتفع الى اعلى في منطقه
السوق العربي والمنطقه المتاخمه للقصر
الجمهوري وهذه الاشتباكات كانت قبل دقائق
من الان سلاح الجو تركز على هذه المناطق
بكثافه ردد من خلالها قوات الدعم السريع
بعدد من المضادات الارضيه وبحسب مشاهداتنا
لم تستطيع هذه المضادات ان تصيب الطائرات
الوقت الذي تم نشر وتداول فيه عدد من
الفيديوهات الخاصه لقوات الدعم السريع
بانها امتلكت سلاحا جديدا خاص بمضادات
الطيران وهذا ان دل انما يدل على انه
هنالك تعزيزا جديدا لقوات الدعم السريع
عند صدقه هذا الفيديو او هذه الصور
المتداوله وفي هذا الصباح ايضا عدد من
الاشتباكات بحسب المعلومات الميدانيه وردت
الينا في منطقه الحلفايه والان ربما نستمع
لعدد من ذوي الانفجارات في المنطقه
المحيطه بمطار الخرطوم والقريبه من منطقه
شرق الخرطوم كل هذه الاهداف تركزت منذ
صباح الباكر وحتى الان وما زالت طائرات
الاستطلاع تحلق وعدد من المناطق في جنوب
الخرطوم ايضا كان للطيران الحربي فيها
اهدافا عسكريه استطاع من خلالها ان ينفذ
تلك الطلعات الجويه
وما زالت هذه الاشتباكات تستمر ما بين
المضادات الارضيه وسلاح الجو ايضا هذا
يعني بطبيعه المعركه وطبيعه العمليه
العسكريه ان سلاح الجو ربما يحاول ان يفرض
يعني شبكه هوائيه كبيره في عمليه الضغط
على قوات الدعم السريع وهذا ما يفتح عدد
من المسارات ربما لقوات المشاه حتى تساهم
في عمليه التمشيط بحسب ما ذكر الجيش في
عده بيانات بانه ما زال مستمرا في عمليه
التمشيط قوات الدعم السريع يبدو انها ما
زالت تتحصن في تلك المناطق وربما احكمت
اقلاق عدد من الشوارع وعدد من الجسور وهذا
يجعل مهمه المشاه صعبه نسبه للدفاعات
ونسبه للتحصينات الموجوده على ارض الواقع
عمرنا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
الاحاطه جديد
في تداعيات المواجهات بين الجيش ودعم
السريع في دارفور اظهرت صور احتراق اكبر
سوق للبقوليات في نيالا عاصمه جنوب دارفور
حيث سقطت قذائف متبادله من طرفي الصراع ما
تسبب في خسائر كبيره بالاسواق التجاريه
بالاقليم
مع ذلك مع الناس الضيوف اللي معانا الضيوف
برضو يقدروا بحوالي كم واربعين نفر دي
كلها عندهم فضائح حرقت في هذه المحل والله
200 جوال عدسيه
ما شاء الله
نذهب الان الى اقليم دارفور معنا من هناك
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه صالح مرحبا بك معنا
في سياق هذه التغطيه قبل قليل كنا مع عمار
من الخرطوم والحديث عن تجدد للشبكات في
محيط القصر الجمهوري ماذا عن الوضع في
اقليم دارفور حتى لساعه ابرز عناوين
المشهد هناك
نعم دعينا نبدا من جنوب دارفور هنالك هدنه
امتدت طويلا لكن تخرق هذه الهدنه في كل
مره سماع اصوات الرصاص التي تسمح في
الصباح وتسمع ايضا في المسافه لكن الجهود
الاهليه مستمره حتى الان وهي تسعى
بمبادرات اهليه ومبادرات للمجتمع هنا
بجنوب دارفور حتى يتم اطلاق ايقاف تام
لاطلاق النار في جنوب دارفور ايضا هنالك
جهود من
الاحياء وشباب الاحياء واللجان الاحياء
تهدف الى حمايه الاحياء من عمليات السلب
والنهب وايضا من عمليات دخول بضائع او
اشياء يتم نهبها من الاسواق نعلم بان
عمليات النهب والسلب قالت اماكن كثيره
واطالت مخازن كثيره في جنوب دارفور حتى
اللحظه وهنالك ضمائر كبير جدا
للمحلات الخاصه والمحلات التجاريه ايضا
بهذه الولايه اما اذا انتقلنا الى غرب
دارفور حتى هذه اللحظه اللجان تعمل على
انزال الوثيقه على ارض الواقع هنالك هدوء
يعني افهم من كلامك لم تبلور
اتفاق القبائل في الجنينه عندما تحدثنا عن
غرب دارفور الذات في اي تطورات على الارض
على الواقع فعلا يعني لم يتم ايقاف هذه
الاشتباكات هنا وهناك بين القبائل في
دارفور
نعم تحدثنا الى لجنه الوساطه وقالت بانها
حتى الان تعمل من اجل عدم تجدد الاشتباكات
لكن ليله البارحه هنالك ايضا فروقات هي
الاتفاق هنالك اعيى ناريه هنالك قناصه ما
زالوا مهتمين في حي الجبل وبالجبل في
الجنينه هنالك اطلاق للنار ايضا لكن تعمل
الوساطه على
اللحاق بكل هذه
التفلتات تحدثنا مع مدير الهلال الاحمر
ايضا وقال بانهم حتى الان تم رفع 23 جثه
متحلله داخل الاحياء في مدينه
الجنينه الوضع الانساني لماذا لا كما هو
لكن دعينا نتحدث للسيد الامير بحر الدين
هو من الاداره الاهليه للمساليد ان يتحدث
لنا عن الوضع في مدينه الجنينه وما تم اهم
اتفاق وكيفيه تنفيذ هذا
امير بحر الدين على قناه العربيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على اشرف المرسلين كل سنه وانتم طيبين
تحيه والتقدير للاستاذ صالح علامه وقناه
العربيه والحدث
خلينا نتكلم يعني عن فرص
تنفيذه الوثيقه
بعد الاحداث المؤلمه التي فقدتنا فيها
كثير من الارواح والممتلكات يبقى ثلاثه
ايام صعبه كانت جدا لم تمر في مدينه من
قبل
تموا توقيعي وثيقه وقفه عدائيات
قبيله المصاليد وبعض القبائل العربيه وانا
اقول المجتمع المحلي
وده الممكن يعني في نقطه الحاضر
حقيقه نتمنى انه هذه الوثيقه تدوم وتنجز
وتلتزم الاطراف في وقت الادعائيات انه وضع
الانساني والوضع الصحي والوضع الامني سيء
خالص
اتمنى انه الاطراف
وثائق كثيره وقع عليها ولكن تخرب في كل
مره يعني ما الجديد في هذه الوثيل في هذه
والله الجديد الى
الموقعين هي الاراده الغالبه للاسف لا
يوجد
طرف حكومي لا توجد كل جهه من الجهات بعيده
وهذا جهد المقيل برعايه كريمه من السلطان
سعد عبد الرحمن بحر الدين ثم توقيع هذه
الوثيقه من مكونات المجتمع المحلي
يعني كخطوه لوقفه اطلاق النار
حصل خراب كبير والحصل تدمير ممنهج لكل
المؤسسات وناب وسلبي كله مؤسسه
المواطنين والدوله منهج من جهه معينه من
متفلتين جرام والله ما بقدر انا احدد لكن
يعني قتلي بطريه بشعه وكبيره وعدد كبير
جدا يعني ما معتدين
كان كبير جدا يعني
مثلا لا توجد احصائيه لاعاده القطه
والجرحات
اللي صعوبه
لم تحصل عدد الشهداء والقتله الاوضاع صعبه
ولازال بعض الناس متوفين في داخل منازل
وفي اماكن بعيده يعني طيب الوضع صعب نتمنى
انه ربنا يزيد هذا البلاء ونتمنى انه كمان
كل الحظ تجيب في السودان كله مش في غير
بيدارفور يعني انا ادعوا قوات الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه شكرا السيد الامير
عبد الرحمن
الاداره الاهليه
للمساليد تحدث لنا عن الوثيقه وعن فرص
انجاح هذه الوثيقه نعود اليكم شكرا جزيلا
لك من اقليم دار فوره صحفي صالح ابو علمه
الان نذهب معكم الى مدينه الجنينه ابو بكر
محمد الشريف مدير جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
السوداني في غرب دارفور اهلا بك معنا ابو
بكر في سياق هذه التغطيه هناك عناوين عده
تتحدث عن ان الوضع الصحي متدهور جدا في
غرب دارفور ما تفاصيل ذلك وحيثياته
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ادى الى تدمير كامل البنيه التحتيه
للمؤسسات بالاضافه لنظام الصحي بتاعه
الولايه بشكل كامل الان كل المستشفيات
خارج الخدمه هذا باب المستشفيات
بكفاءه ضعيفه جدا جدا فقط في الخيارات
بتاعه الخدمات بتاعت الاسعافات
كل المخازن الموجوده بدايه الدوره تم
نهبها تماما ما في اي خدمات موجوده بتاعه
الخدمات الصحيه تماما الهلال الاحمر
السوداني الان يعمل
بصوره جيده منذ
خمس ايام بدانا بنخذ
من المناطق مختلفه بعد ما طلبنا فتره
الشغل بتاعه الجزر بدينا بنحاول نخزي حتى
بالتعاون مع بعض المنظمات الموجوده
بسهوله بيسر يعني تتحدثون عن وجود ممرات
امنه لانه الوضع مختلف في الخرطوم بطبيعه
الحال
الهلال الاحمر السوداني هو مقبول لدى كل
الاطراف الان هنا بندخل في كل المواقف من
شرعيه صعوبه لكن
للاسف الشديد كل البنيه التحتيه بتاعه
الهلال الاحمر تمت تدمر تماما المكتب
بتاعه الهلال الاحمر تدمر بشكل تماما حتى
العربات يتحركت بعد الخصائب اثناء
المبادلات غير مقصوده مباشره مع مساعده
الهلال الاحمر لكن طبعا وقع في موقف ختال
وتدمر بحريق كامل
المجهود او اقل كبستيجات مؤسسه تقدر تقدم
خدماته ولكن احنا
بارادفنا ما هنجيب وهنقدم الخدمات بكل لكل
لكل الاطراف
مع جهات دوليه امميه ربما لايصال مساعدات
وهل حصلتم على اي منها
نعمل جنبنا نجمت مع الصليب الاحمر الدولي
اتصل علينا بعد المنظمات اللي هو اول حاجه
اول حاجه يتصل عليه اتصل علينا وطلبه حتى
انه بعد المعلومات على اساس ان المبدا
نشتغل شغل مشترك الشغل المشترك نضع
خطط نقدر نعمل التدخل المباشره سواء كان
على مستوى المصابين او على مستوى
النازحين او الان في مراكز العلاج الجديده
الاصل
مراكزهم تبرر بشكل كامل
في التواصل
على اساس نحول الحالات الحرجة هل
تمتدرين المستشفيات زي ما ذكرتها قبل شويه
هي خارجه عن الخدمه في بعض الحالات محتاجه
لعمليات
بالتنسيق مع كل جهات بنفس الاعداد وما
الصليب الاحمر عايزين نحول الحالات الى
الجاره تشاد على اساس يتم عمل عملياتهم
العمليات الكبيره
[موسيقى]
رقم تقديري
المصابين انه لو بنتكلم بحاجه تقريريه ما
اقل من 600 مصاب بين
اصابات طفيفه الى اصابات كبيره الان هنا
بتحتاج لعمليات احنا بنتكلم عن عدد تقريبي
بين
50 او بين 70 الى 90 حاله خارجه محتاجه
لتحويل لو جينا نتكلم عن حالات العاديه
يعني في
المستشفى العسكري الان يستقبل اي حاله
ويتم التعامل مع الحالات المتوسطه الكسور
وحيره من الحاجات الاتيه
المستشفى العسكري شغال بكفاءه متوسطه الان
في بعض المستوطنات الخاصه في حول الجمارك
برضو كانت تتعاون تقدم بعض الخدمات
بمستويات متوسطه اما الحاجات الكبيره
اختصاصيا لا يوجد اختصاصين او حتى ولو
وجود علاقه تفاصيل اقتصاصين من غير اي
كفاءه بتاعه مؤسسات او ما في تعيين باللذه
للمؤسسات الكبيره لو كان موجود في تامين
المستشفى الجنان التعليميه ممكن يقدر كل
المشاكل اللي موجوده لو في تعميم كامل
المستشفى
ممكن يقدر يقول كل المشاكل الموجوده في
الولايه لكن للاسف الشديد ما في تعميم
وهذا موجود التامين ادى انه
ادى انه الناس مضطرين انه يدوم للاتجاه
الاخر الان
الناس يرجعوا لصوت العقل كل الناس كل
الاطراف يحاولوا انه هي حاله حاله حاله
انسانيه حرجه جدا جدا الناس زي ما تمت
الاتفاقيه نتمنى انه الناس يحاولوا يمشوا
على الاتفاقيه على اساس انه تكون في ممرات
عامه في سلام على الاقل يجب الناس يقدرون
يقدم الاخافه للجوعه
والناس الذين يفترشون الارض السماء في نفس
اجرها
نقدر نلحقهم في بعض
العمليات
فنتمنى من الله سبحانه وتعالى انه يساعدنا
نقدر نقدم حاجه للمواطن او نقد النساء
المواطن
الجهات التي تعنى بالجسم الطبي والصحي في
السودان نقابه اطباء السودان ايضا قالت
لنا قبل ساعات بنفس المطالب هم يطالبون
كاولويه فتح ممرات امنه ومن ثم الحديث عن
ايصال المستلزمات وانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
على كل حال شكرا جزيلا لك من الجنينه ابو
بكر محمد شريف مدير جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
السوداني في غرب دارفور
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه كشف سكرتير
نقابه اطباء السودان عطيه عبد الله عطيه
كشف للعربيه عن وجود اكثر من 12 الف مريض
معرضون للموت بسبب الاوضاع الصحيه مشددا
على ضروره فتح ممرات امنه لايصال المعونات
الطبيه للمتضررين
الاعداد في ازدياده شديد وهي متواليه
متوقعه بعد يعني تزايد العسكريه سوف يكون
هنالك اكثر من 12 الف مريض معرض للموت
الان نحن لدينا تقارير من ان هنالك عدد من
المرضى توفي داخل منازلهم
المياه في المستشفيات وفي المنازل يشكل
مشكله كبيره جدا في ظل عدم وصول هذه
المعينات سوف يتعرض 12,000 للموت نحن
قلناها وكررناها ان طرفي الصراع في
السودان تركوا الشعب السوداني امام خيارين
اما الموت بالرصاص او الموت بالمرض حلو
البسيطه فقط فتح ممرات امنه بالتاكيد سوف
نصل الى هذه المستشفيات سوف يستطيع
الداعمين الوصول وتوصيل معاناتهم بالتاكيد
سوف يعني يتكاثف الجميع في في هذه الازمه
نعود ونتابع معكم هذه الصور مباشره حيث
تتصاعد اعمده الدخان في سماء المدينه جديد
المعلومات تفيد بان الجيش السوداني يحاول
التقدم نحو القصر الجمهوري وقوات الدعم
تتصدى بمضادات الطيران هذا وفقا لمصادر
العربيه حتى هذه الساعه طبعا نكاد نسمع
بشكل واضح اصوات ودوي الانفجارات وايضا
كما افاد مراسل العربيه وحتى شبكت
الصحفيين بالمعلومات التي تفيد بسماع
اصوات الطائرات الحربيه التي كانت تحلق في
سماء الخرطوم منذ ساعات هذا الصباح الباكر
وسمع صوت هائل لقذائف وايضا مدفعيات فيما
مضادات الطائرات كانت تتصدى للطائرات
فبالتالي هذه الاصوات الهائله للانفجارات
تسمع في محيط القصر الجمهوري وفي محيط
ايضا في منطقه الخرطوم بالعاصمه نتابع
معكم اذا هذه المشاهد مباشره وحتى ايضا
نسمع بالصوت الطبيعي صوت الاشتباكات
نسمعها بوضوح ونتابع تصاعد اعمده الدخان
بشكل واضح وبدات تزداد كثافه في سماء
المدينه الاصوات واضحه جدا لما يدور الان
لتجدد لاشتباكات بين طرفي الصراع حتى هذه
الساعه في محيط القصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم
كانت المعلومات تفيد بان هذه المواجهات
اصلا لا تزال مستمره وان كانت خفت حدتها
ولا تزال طائرات الجيش تحلق في سماء
العاصمه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ترد
بالمقابل بمضادات ارضيه فبالتالي نتابع
معكم لتجدد الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم الصوت ابرز دليل على
ذلك كما نتابع حيث سمع وفق شهود عيان
والان نحن نسمع مباشره لصوت القذائف وايضا
اصوات هائله للانفجارات كانت يتردد صداها
منذ ساعات هذا الصباح الى الان هذه
اللحظات تتجدد اشتباكات في محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم
قال المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر
السوداني اسامه ابو بكر قال للعربيه ان
الوضع الانساني في الجنينه ماساوي واضاف
ان الوضع الامني في السودان يشهد تحسنا
نسبيا مقارنه بالايام الماضيه
بهدوء كامل وعايزين هدنه معلومه مسارات
امنه واضحه كل الناس يعلمونها لتمكيننا
وتمكين المنظمات الانسانيه الاخرى من
العمل بتاع العمل بكل الطاقه القصوى بما
يتناسب مع حجم الماساه التي تمر بها
العاصمه
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الصحه السودانيه
تسجيل ست اصابات جديده بولايه الخرطوم
وحاله وفاه واحده بولايه وسط دارفور
ليقترب بذلك عدد الاصابات التراكب من 5000
اصابه و550 حاله وفاه في جميع انحاء
البلاد اوضح التقرير ان الهدوء يسود كافه
الولايات عدا ولايه الخرطوم ووسط دارفور
لكن الجهات الطبيه تواصل تسجيل اصابات
ووفيات نتيجه الحرب القائمه
وفي محاوله لتخفيف اعباء القتال الداخلي
بين قوات الجيش ودعم السريع الذي يدور في
السودان منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يخاطر مستشفى
خاص في ام درمان بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء
الحوامل واجراء ولاده دون مقابل مادي وفي
ظل ظروفا امنيه وانسانيه توصف بالكارثيه
ترد المؤسسات الصحيه
يرافق استمرار القتال في السودان
لكن مستشفى خاصا في ام درمان
ينجح بفتح ابوابه لخدمه النساء الحوامل
مجانا
في ظل نادى من شبه كامل للامن
وارتفاع اثمان المستلزمات في السوق
السوداء
اكثر من عشره اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
320 عمليه ولاده قيصريه اجراها منذ اندلاع
القتال
فيما تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان
اكثر من خمسين مستشفى بالخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل
وتحذيراته من انهيار القطاع الصحي تتواصل
وفي تداعيات الاقتتال المستمر بالسودان
اعلنت الامم المتحده ان اسعار السلع
الاساسيه من الوقود الى المواد الغذائيه
والمياه المعبئه ارتفعت بنسبه 40 الى 60%
واكثر في بعض المناطق وفاد برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي بان نحو ثلث السكان البالغ عددهم
اكثر من 46 مليون شخص كانوا يعانون من
الجوع قبل اندلاع الصراع مشيرا الى ان
العنف يمكن ان يغرق ملايين الاشخاص في
الجوع
في هذه الاثناء وصل وكيل الامين العام
للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
وصل الى السودان للوقوف على عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره وكان الامين العام
انطونيو غوتيريش قرر ارسال جرافيتسي الى
المنطقه في ضوء التدهور السريع للازمه
الانسانيه في السودان يذكر ان لجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر تمكنت من ايطالي
اول شحنه مساعدات انسانيه عن طريق الجو
الى مدينه بورتسودان مع دخول الاشتباكات
اسبوعها الثالث
نذهب لمتابعه عمليات النزوح على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه مباشره من مرسى مدينه
ابو سمبل مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان احمد
ما الذي رصد طموحه هذه الساعه لتدفق
الاعداد هل مازال بذات الوتيره
الى حد ما يعني على الرغم من انه لا توجد
اي احصاءات رسميه في الايام الاخيره فيما
يتعلق تحديدا باعداد النازحين القادمين من
السودان ولكنها لم نلحظ اي تغيير في
الوتيره المشهد كما هو هناك استمرار وتدفق
للنزحين التدفق اغلبه الان ينصب على مركز
او منفذ قصته القلب البري هذا هو المنفذ
الذي يشهد حاليا او في الفتره الاخيره
النسبه الاكبر من القادمين من السودان
الذين يستمرون في البقوس ربما لمده يومين
حتى انتهاء جميع الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالسلامه ومن ثم العبور الى الجانب المصري
من المنفذ ومن ثم التوجه لمده 60 كيلو متر
قبل استقلال العبرات النيليه والوصول الى
حيث اقف الان الى مرسى ابو سمبل لاستئناف
رحلاتهم مره اخرى الى المدد المصريه
وتحديدا مدينه اسوان ربما ما لفت نظري
خلال الايام الاخيره ان هناك بدا ان هناك
تفاوت ربما في كثير من
جاليه المصريه الراغبين في العوده مره
اخرى الى مصر يعني بعد توقف الرحلات
الطائرات هذا فيما يتعلق بالجانب الميداني
هناك ايضا تحركات رايناها في الامس على
اكثر من صعيد فيما يتعلق بالجانب السياسي
من تحركات مصريه للكثير من الاطراف او
بالتخاطب مع الكثير من الاطراف القاريه
والاقليميه والعربيه والدوليه في محاوله
يعني رائد الصدع في السودان ما بين
الطرفين المتنازعين والانتقال من مرحله
الهدن الهشه الى مرحله وقف لي القتال ومن
ثم استئناف للحمار والعوده بالمشهد
السياسي الى خريطته المعتاده قبل ان
تتفاقم هذه الظاهره وتظهر يعني ظاهرتها
تاثيراتها السلبيه على دول المحيط من خلال
عمليات النزوح والتاثيرات السلبيه
اقتصاديا وامنيا على هذه الدول ومن بينها
مصر على طبيعه الحال التي تتابع عن كثب
جميع التطورات التي تحدث في السودان على
مدار الساعه ونحن نشكرك الان مباشره كنت
معنا من مرسى مدينه ابو سمبل مراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان
[موسيقى]
كل المراكز معطله بحاجه الحرب الدائره
الان نحن برامز ظروف خاصه
نعمل في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم
امكانيات اللي ما موجوده عندنا
بعض الادويه والمعدات
ذكر الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
حسين ابراهيم طه ان اللجنه التنفيذيه
للمنظمه تعقد اجتماعا طارئا في جده
لمناقشه تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وذلك
بناء على دعوه من السعوديه التي تتراس
القمه الاسلاميه الحاليه واللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي وجدد
طه مناشدته بوقف اطلاق نار دائم في
السودان والجوع الى الحوار واستئناف
العمليه السياسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات